have you guys started reaching the point
where you're playing the junket game
i've never played the junket game what
is the jungkook game where you try to
like put a certain word
into the answer no i think we're just
grateful that you know we even have a
movie
anybody who's time to be honest anyone
cares
i think we're far too grateful to play
we just want the company frankly
[Laughter]
i thought you both did such a great job
with this and um i loved the script for
this i thought
ron and jim did such a great job i'm
curious for both of you
because a script like this is not the
norm um what is what was it like for
both of you reading this for the first
time
and were you like i need to make this i
think we both were
right away you know scripts like this
don't come along very often and they do
stand out like a sore thumb
you know they worked on it for 15 years
and it really shows there's
it's just it's just one of the best
scripts i've ever read and i think the
only script i've ever read
after we finished filming just because i
was still
intrigued by it you know and my only
complaint about this process is that i
couldn't have been longer
you know it's hard to raise money for
films like this and we made it really
quickly
um but it was such a complete
rich complex world and those are the
ones you just kind of want to camp out
within and explore as much as possible
like a great play you know um
it was it was really hard every day to
walk away from the scenes
because you kind of just they're so rich
you just want to kind of take another
stab
it had so much soul in it it had so much
soul it was so delicate
it was like poetry really and that's so
rare it's not there's no like crashes
and bangs and running around you know
what i mean it was like purely two
people talking
trying to work each other out really
slowly trying to find a way out of their
pain recognizing
each other finding solace and intimacy
and um like a blossoming a blossoming
[Music]
you got this you got this sounded out
[Music]
a blossoming of individual selves you
know
um maybe for the first time in their
lives and i just thought that was so
profound
and beautiful and it really moved me and
um
i could feel this kind of like yeah it
made me ache a little bit
and um and you know when you feel things
when you read something a script like
that
you go that's such a good sign and i
hope we can try and
animate that feeling a little bit even
if it's one person who watches it and
feels it
takes place in the late 1850s in upstate
new york
and at that time life was so hard
and i think that the the film does a
great job of just reminding you
that just each day was a struggle to be
alive and
no one was you know love was such a
luxury do either of you think you could
have survived in that time
because i definitely could not have no
no chance
i think well you know what's so
interesting about it is that
the innocence you know that there's no
there's no knowledge of some other way
of existing you know except for what
came before
them i love that line where
where abigail says imagine what it was
like for our grandmothers
oh they had it they had it hard
you know um from the position we sit
today my god
it seems truly nightmarish to not have
the freedom to love who you want to love
to not um
have a moment to yourself to not have
an opportunity to get an education or
uh consider any dreams of your own
all of that's really unappealing to me
but there are certain things
about that way of living that um were
quite seductive to me when i was there i
was so struck
even just um working for a few weeks
in the remote countryside in romania
just struck by how
fragmented my thoughts have become in
these modern times
you know you're just constantly pinged
and pulled in different directions
and texted and emailed and accessible
almost 24 hours a day and
the the solitude and that kind of
monastic way of living
is not something to shake a stick at is
that an expression i don't know
what that means um but yeah i think
there's a lot to be learned
um from from from those people who
um and i certainly i suppose this year i
learned quite a bit
from indigenous peoples who engage with
the natural world in a much more
sensitive
and connected way um i was quite struck
by all of that
but yeah the hard labor no thanks
cow milking not not a walk in the park i
mean
i definitely i'd you know i i felt like
very in tune with tally in a way
because i think i don't know she i just
imagined her to be
the kind of personality that might
always wonder what's beyond
you know and uh and there must have been
so many women
throughout all of history through all
the centuries who
who questioned the order and the system
and imagined a world that didn't have
that
and i think she really represents that
and you know
the fact that the allegory of the story
the fact that she's kind of
distinguished that light is
is extinguished i think is true to
the the those lights you know that were
probably
going off everywhere all around the
world that that asked for more and of
course you know
women that fought for more than they
were
told they had and were allowed and i
think you know her
tally is one one woman's story from the
past who
who wanted more from love you know and
and abigail wanted like you know even
getting an atlas or like literal
literate literature or poetry or you
know
imagine that maybe she could be creative
in some way and and tally
wanted to be with someone who made her
really happy
and that was what she asked for and and
so i think
yeah the the the the bigger allegory of
of that kind of
um imagination sort of being
snuffed out or extinguished um
everywhere probably happened so much and
i almost felt like
our ancestors that risked doing that and
that came
you know that sometimes that was fatal
they were paving the way for more and
more people to be able to finally
actually be able to you know and break
through that and um
and here we are today at least you know
our lives so privileged
when abigail's starting to fall in love
with tally and she she starts using all
this
nautical imagery i'm finding it so
[ __ ] moving this person who's never
seen the sea
she's read a few books um that maybe
have described great storms or
[ __ ] at sea you know and she's using
this imagery
that she doesn't that she's she's only
learned from in books but she's trying
um in her way and with her words
on the page her written words to
extend her world you know it's it's so
it's so moving and tragic to me
you know these women these two women who
in their very different ways
are just longing to reach out beyond the
limitations of their you know
three square mile existence
uh i definitely before i run out of time
i want to talk about mona and the
filmmaking because i thought she did
such a great job with this
can you sort of talk about the fact that
it was more natural lighting
and you were filming on celluloid and
you know she just did such a great job i
know i'm so
curious how many people are going to be
watching this now on on small screens
and
this really is a film for the cinema and
we were so lucky that we got to take it
to venice and see it with our real
audience um
the impact of that is just that what the
genesecua about celluloid that it just
feels like it's living and breathing on
the screen you know it's just there is
something different about it and the
sound design and all of the elements
working together
i'll be curious to see what the
experience is like i hope
not too many people if they have the
option you know
we'll try to watch it with the best
sound system they can hook up and
on a bigger screen but um she really is
a filmmaker and she thinks like a
filmmaker and she
can do that a seemingly impossible thing
of
spinning all the plates of imagining the
elements of post-production and color
correction that will tie things together
and you know
we just sort of show up and
and and stand there as it were you know
um
she's she is a very skilled um
maestro also like you know i i thought
it made me think about the crown
actually while being on the set because
what really helped us like feel like
royals was that they built buckingham
palace and we were actually shooting
like in you know a lot of really royal
sort of rooms and whatever whatever the
hell you were around london and outside
rather than being like oh like how the
hell the [ __ ] do you do you act being a
princess
which i have no idea about like to
actually go oh okay
if you you're in this habitat then it
might bring up these feelings
you know of privilege or feel like
you're you're less than
the situation you find yourself in or
whatever and it's the same for for this
movie in a way what mona did was because
she built the farms in the middle of
nowhere
in you know it was my home and and
catherine's
home and and so you sort of felt the
remoteness
you know in the middle of transylvania
you know you had to like
hike half an hour to set sometimes and
it helped you embody the whole situation
you know and therefore the longing and
therefore the
the uh the silences and the things that
you wished you had
and you know so it was massively helpful
and mona really it was to her that she
did that and
also weirdly the shooting on film it
almost felt true to
like uh like history somehow you know it
just felt truer it felt less like digi
and none of the uh none of their lives
was remotely digital
um yeah gotta go i'm just gonna say
again congrats
and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating maintain you know
uh some sort of you know what i mean
we're just grateful i'm grateful for you
thanks stephen have a great day